you will hear some very strange things
from citizens sometimes that according
to the theory of relativity the passage
of time is an illusion that time doesn't
really change that there really is no
motion that everything is somehow it's
this thing all together and frozen and I
find those claims to be frankly
incredible and review more amazing a
discovery than anything that's happened
in the discreet mankind to find out that
all of change in all time and the
passage of time doesn't really happen so
I've been asking myself how did people
come to think that and I think the
answer is this that when we think about
space and time and general relativity we
try and use the geometrical tools the
mathematical tools were developed for
extracting geometrical structure and
that those tools were originally
developed just for space like for
Euclidean geometry for understanding
structure of space around us and in
space there is no direction there's no
fundamental intrinsic directionality in
spatial structure so you wouldn't
naturally develop mathematical tools to
represent intrinsic directionality and
what's happened is taking those tools
that were developed for one purpose you
then use them in this other purpose for
not only describing space the time and
you end up saying things like oh time is
just another dimension like space time
is spatial eyes and in doing so you lose
track of the directionality of time you
lose track of the fact that time is
fundamentally different from space in
this has an intrinsic direction to it it
goes from the past to the future and we
would never say space glows from the
east to the west or the top to the
bottom anymore than the bottom to the
top so what I've been doing recently is
developing a different mathematical way
of representing geometrical structure
that has directionality built into it
very natural way that you can represent
both things that have an intrinsic
directionality and and things that don't
and in that picture it looks like the
right thing to say about relativity is
not that it's spatialized this time
which makes the direction of time very
puzzling but there is temporal isin
states that really what's fundamental is
temporal structure is time structure and
that in a certain sense spatial
structure derives from that